Lee is with us in a washington DC hi Lee
how are you I'm doing okay thanks
thanks for taking my call sure how can I
help I've been married a long time
almost 18 years and about two years ago
my husband found out that I had spent
about $30,000 and didn't tell him so
within that time frame we had lost a
child so he separated the money and I
went back to work to try to pay off my
part of the debt well when I realized I
haven't really done much so I asked him
if he would take FPU with me previously
we had done your plan but we hadn't
taken f2u and he told me no he doesn't
want to take it with me because he
doesn't see any progress so I'm just
calling to find out if you think I
should take it on my own um how long
have you been married I said you said 18
years I'm sorry how long ago was this
that you disclosed that you had lied to
him about 30,000 bucks
I didn't disclose he found out oh I wish
I would have disclosed it would have
turned out much better about two years
ago and what is the lack of the lack of
progress is what in his mind that you've
not paid the debt down or that you're
still just spending like crazy a little
bit of both not spending like crazy but
not putting all of my money that I'm
currently making or most of it on the
debt what are you doing with it um I
have no idea foolishness I guess not
really anything I buy things here and
there and I kind of pay the minimums on
my debt and that's about it
well I this is a difficult deal because
there's kind of two sides of the
equation for me let me just kind of talk
it out with you okay there's your side
of the equation where you you lied
big-time to your husband he caught you
so he doesn't trust you anymore
then you took a job but that's really
all you've done to fix the mess because
more importantly than you take a not
taking a job or taking a job is that you
and changed anything
you're still disorganized you're still
not handling money you're still spending
it all that's problem number one one
side of the equation the other side of
the equation is I really don't like a
situation where a husband is treating a
wife or a wife is treating a husband
over a two-year period of time as if
you're his daughter and he's punishing
you trying to make you learn him learn a
lesson or something that's a not a
healthy marriage solution either so I
don't like his solution I don't blame
him for being pissed off I don't like
his solution and I don't like your
behavior your your unwillingness to
change and so you guys really have some
a lot of stuff to work on I do think the
best scenario is for you to earn his
trust while by handling money well but
not by being abandoned by him but by
working with him and so I think his
abandoning you to your mess is unhealthy
and I think you're like a change is
unhealthy because you're not you know I
I don't blame him for not trusting you
you haven't earned any but also do blame
him for just leaving you out there on
your own he's you're not a pencil a
teenager you're his wife of 18 years and
so you know I would approach this a lot
differently it would be it might even be
more uncomfortable for you if I were
married to you because we would be
working on this or we would be working
in the marriage counselor's office to
bring our marriage to an end because
you're going to frickin get to I'm not
going to be married to somebody I can't
trust right not for a long time
I mean I'll work with you for a while
and I'm not I'm not lacking in grace but
eventually you know it's just like if
someone's an alcoholic or if someone's
you know doing drugs and they say I'm
clean I'm clean well the only way
somebody wants to stay married to a
former addict is they come clean stay
clean but that when that trust is just
continually broken eventually they give
up and they go why would
be crazy to stay in this cycle so the
and that's kind of what he's facing but
he's not handling it very well so I I
think I would suggest FPU for both of
you and marriage counseling for both of
you and if he won't go to either I would
just go to marriage counseling and wait
on FPU until you can get him to go with
you okay because I'm afraid this is
going to make it worse it might help you
but I don't want to drive a wedge
between you and him any further you
follow me I want you guys to want your
marriage to be healed I don't want it to
be any further than this so and he he
did pay off all of anything with his
name on it
he paid yeah I know but there's this
there's a lot of selfishness here on his
part I mean if he gets sick you got to
make him soup in bed so it's for better
for worse for richer for poorer in
stupid and not until death do us part I
mean that's how that works and so you're
all in when you're married it's not like
well you know this is not a joint
venture where you can just go I'm not
going to fix my partner's problem it's
your wife for goodness sakes so now I'll
tell you what you might do and again the
big the big answer is you need a
marriage counselor okay big time both of
you now the smaller answer might be and
don't do this instead in other words do
that one but but as a part of this what
if you sat down with him and said okay
I'm going to go through financial piece
you know I'm not I'm gonna start working
on my budget would you help me with it
okay would you help me do a written plan
and then would you work with me and show
me because you're better at handling
money than I am and help me you know put
together a game plan to pay down on this
debt and then if I do that for two
months with you helping me would you go
to FPU with me then I will try that and
try to earn some try to create a
conversation a dialogue here and then
you know say under what circumstances
would you go to FPU and will you help me
with this are you just gonna abandon me
you know cuz you're not you're not
saying I did a right thing you're not
defending it I didn't hear you anyway I
think you said I don't know Kalyn
what I did was stupid yeah okay so I
mean I think you just reach out go hey
help me with this and you're asking I'm
not saying buy help I'm not saying ask
him write a check today although I think
you should write checks but I think that
comes later but I think today you're
just saying help me by coaching me and
showing me how to do this and walking
with me and then I'll take my money and
do with it what you would do if you were
doing this how would you handle it and
so you know just try to get him involved
in your situation if I do that for two
months or three months
would you agree then to go to FPU and
would you agree to sit down the marriage
counselor with me because we've got a
mess here cause you got Pam you got some
pretty seriously damaged trust I got I
tell you Lee what some people don't
realize is that's called we call it
financial infidelity in the financial
coaching world and for some people it's
hard to believe but for some people this
broken trust is harder to get over the
sexual infidelity for some people now
that wouldn't be the case with me but it
would be but but for some people it
touches the same place in your soul this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you